5.5 million young people under 25 are
unemployed in Europe right now this
represents almost 23% and in some places
such as Spain or Greece the situation is
even worse with youth unemployment rates
of over 50% but there are solutions one
of them is called the youth guarantee
the European Commission has identified
the youth guarantee scheme aimed at
young people under 25 as one of the best
methods to reduce unemployment this is
why it's asked all EU countries to
implement such schemes with youth
guarantees no one is left behind each
country ensures that every young
European is offered a job or an
apprenticeship traineeship or other
further education at least four months
after leaving school or their last
employment some countries like Finland
and Austria are already doing it and it
works the way the guarantee is set up
could differ between countries there is
no one-size-fits-all model what matters
is the outcome that no young person is
left alone without support or the chance
to find a good job the EU is trying to
help countries to get the schemes up and
running you can help too if you speak up
and promote youth guarantees in your
country